[Music]
honey things haven't spiraled up control
the moment I left everything's great
[Music]
done properly parenting is a heroic
looks normal to me is freaky
did you wash your hands with soap did
you dry them it hurt all vegetables all
vegetable I did so are we going to talk
about it what the elephant in the room
what elephant mom's new job
it's time to make some wrong things
right now they bring supers back into
the sunlight we need to change people's
perceptions about superheroes and
Elastigirl is our best play better than
me I'll watch the kids no problem do a
dad they want us to do it I don't know
that way why would they change math math
is math hey honey everything's great
[Music]
he's in excellent health that is freaky
you know it's crazy right to help my
family I gotta leave it to fix the law I
gotta break it you got to before kids
can have that choice thank you young man
combustion imminent what does that mean
it means fire Robert
[Music]
the screen sledder interrupts this
program for an important announced that
it might get weird I'll be there
[Music]